[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein es ist nur
eine zahl und es ist nur ein wort aber
beide haben es in sich die zahl und das
wort 7,4 prozent inflationsrate das
heißt die preise steigen in einem tempo
wie es die bundesrepublik seit über 40
jahren nicht erlebt hat der höchste
stand seit oktober
1981 das haben wir seit heute amtlich
von den statistikern spüren tun wir es
längst diese zahl und dieses wort
bedeuten eben auch neue fragen neue
unsicherheit und neue sorgen stefanie
dosch viel hatten astrid mahlow und sohn
johann noch nie 1500 euro etwas über der
armutsgrenze
nun hat sich die stromrechnung fast
verdoppelt 70 euro zusätzlich das
teurere leben kaum noch finanzierbar
mehr arbeiten kann die grafikdesignerin
als alleinerziehende nicht die
einschnitte deutlich
am spülmaschine stützte und ich was von
hand ab dann habe ich immer gerne
gebadet das ist jetzt auch nur noch
einmal die woche
noch mehr bei aldi einkaufen mal zwei
edeka
und bio ist auch nicht drin das ist
einfach so
steigende mieten explodieren der
energie- und lebensmittelpreise für
immer mehr menschen reicht das
erarbeitete geld kaum noch in der
hauptstadt fährt laut check nadolski
taxi seit 30 jahren der spritpreis
explodierte das kratzt auch an seiner ex
ich verdiene einfach weniger die sind
statt niedrigerer sektor jetzt habe ich
800 euro was soll ich denn sonst machen
also es sind keine großen sprung
ermöglicht es wird und sowieso erstmal
in ein oder zwei jahren erreichen wenn
wenn die rücklagen aufgebraucht sind
wenn wir uns neue klamotten nicht so oft
kaufen können wenn wir keinen urlaub
machen können er ist die pandemie dann
der krieg tausende von taxifahrern
stiegen in berlin auf einen anderen
beruf um nadolski ist froh über seine
frau die als altenpflegerin mitverdient
im traditionsgasthaus ebel müssen sie
die steigenden preise an die kunden
weitergeben so schonend wie möglich der
chef rechnet vor der strompreis seit
2020 fast doppelt gas verdreifacht und
3000 euro energiekosten pro monat das
sind 15 prozent des umsatzes
es ist nicht nur gas und strom auch alle
anderen zulieferer ob es der
getränkelieferant ist der
fleischlieferant ist ob es entsorgungs
form sind alle nehmen einen energie auf
schlag ein strom auf schlag ein benzin
aufschlag was auch immer wie immer
ausgestattet wird und wir müssen schnell
handeln wir können jetzt nicht
monatelang warten über die preise
erhöhen denn wir werden sind ja jetzt
schon davon betroffen doch was tun wenn
keine arbeit kein geld da ist bei der
caritas beraten sie sozialhilfe
empfänger geben tipps wo strom gespart
werden kann denn diese kosten zahlt das
sozialamt meist nicht die nachfrage in
den letzten monaten gigantisch
anschaue blutet mir das herz es trifft
wie meistens die ärmsten das ist
wirklich ganz eng gestrickt und das
alles zusammen wird schwierig schwierig
schwierig astrid mahlow und der sohn
johann nebenan der osten da wo andere
urlaub machen ihr kleines paradies für
sie unbezahlbar
ja was hilft um die inflation in den
griff zu bekommen ein alter spruch
lautet erstens die richtige geldpolitik
zweitens die richtige geldpolitik und ja
drittens die richtige geldpolitik die
europäische zentralbank hatte in der
vergangenheit ja immer beschwichtigt
alles nur vorübergehend das hat sich als
trugschluss erwiesen valerie haller
guten abend wird dann die ezb jetzt den
zins wecker hören ja davon kann man
ausgehen ziemlich laut sogar der wecker
für die europäische zentralbank bedeutet
diese hartnäckig hohe inflation ja vor
allem eines druck von ihrem kurs des
billigen geldes abzuweichen zumal die
meisten ökonomen davon ausgehen dass die
inflation nicht nur da ist sondern
vermutlich auch erstmal bleibt zumindest
bis jahresende laut offizieller ezb
linie müssen erst die anleihekäufe
auslaufen bevor es zinsschritte möglich
sind einige zeit danach könnten laut ezb
chefin lagarde die zinsen steigen viele
hier tippen auf juli das wäre dann aber
wahrscheinlich auch erst der anfang
einer ganzen reihe von zinserhöhungen in
den kommenden monaten jetzt ist es
offenbar so dass vier von fünf deutschen
ihren konsum bereits einschränken laut
umfrage und das füttern ja zu weiteren
folgen oder ja könnte es die umfrage
deckt sich ja auch mit dem drastisch
gesunkenen verbrauchervertrauen die
menschen sind natürlich unsicher das
haben wir ja auch in dem beitrag gesehen
wie viel sie sich noch wie lange leisten
können und sparen oder schieben größere
anschaffungen erst einmal auf die lange
bank und tatsächlich führen die
preissteigerung ja zu realen
einkommensverlusten muss man mehr für
energie ausgeben bleibt weniger für
konsum- oder investitionen und das
bremst am ende natürlich auch die
wirtschaft immer mehr ökonomen warnen
daher vor einem abschwung in europa wenn
die zinsen steigen dann wächst
zusätzlich die gefahr einer rezession
denn höhere zinsen würden wohl die
inflation eindämmen könnten aber auch
schnell die wirtschaft abwürgen die ezb
steckt also nach wie vor in einer
wirklich kniffliges dilemma valerie
haller herzlichen dank für diese
erläuterungen heute abend
deutsche parlamentarier stimmen mit
großer mehrheit für schwere waffen
lieferungen an die ukraine
schlagzeilen wie diese lesen die
menschen heute in kamerun israel in
dubai taiwan und auf kuba wenn es dem
bundestag darum ging ein symbolisches
signal und um die welt zu senden dann
ist ihm das heute gelungen was die
schlagzeilen nicht wiedergeben ist was
vorher geschah der streit zwischen
regierung und opposition die
diskussionen auch innerhalb der
ampelkoalition um richtung kurs und
kommunikation und auch der teilweise
heftige schlagabtausch heute noch mal im
parlament darüber berichtet thomas reich
hat
eigentlich so der bundestag an diesem
morgen über waffen für die ukraine
entscheiden zunächst aber geht es mehr
um diesen leeren platz und den der sonst
dort sitzt um kanzler chance trotz der
last minute einigung zwischen ampel und
unions opposition auf einen gemeinsamen
antrag friedrich merz hat sich
vorgenommen kräftig auszuteilen gegen
scholz der bundeskanzler hat über wochen
die diskussion über die frage ob der
ukraine der nun waffen geliefert werden
sollten oder nicht hingehalten
offengelassen
ausweichend beantwortet das ist zögern
das ist zaubern und das ist
ängstlichkeit die spd dagegen behauptet
man habe nur sechs wärter verändert um
die union zu überzeugen den ampel antrag
mitzutragen ich habe hier eigentlich auf
meinem zettel draufstehen dank an die
union weil er merz und ich muss ihnen
das in aller emotionalität auch sagen
das hätte heute eine staatspolitische
rede von ihnen werden können es ist aber
das ist eine parteipolitische rede es
ist ein spagat den nuts versuch
zustimmung in der sache kritik am
kanzler der mit seiner entscheidung für
panzerlieferungen anfang der woche eine
atemberaubende kehrtwende hingelegt hat
doch selbst die linke die
waffenlieferungen ablehnt findet der
märz spagat glück nicht
ihnen geht es nicht um die ukraine ihn
geht es um profilierung und in
politischen geländegewinn gerade mit
blick auf die wahlen in schleswig
holstein dort weil das schaf und das ist
inakzeptabel meine damen klar auch die
afg es gegen waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine fordert gar trotz putins
angriffskrieg russland entgegen zu
kommen und noch mal geht es um den
leeren stuhl wir streiten über die
zukunft deutschlands
es geht um krieg und frieden auch in
mitteleuropa und herr scholz reist der
kirschblüte nach japan die kirschblüte
indes war in tokio schon längst vor gut
einem monat um genau zu sein scholz
sieht bei seiner ankunft heute davon
nichts mehr weit weg in tokio bei ihm
zur großen linie was in berlin viele als
unentschlossen kritisieren auch die
einigkeit mit der unions opposition wird
mit abstand weniger brüchig ich bin sehr
dankbar für die klare unterstützung die
der deutsche bundestag heute der politik
der von mir geführten regierung gegeben
hat das zeigt dass man in einer so
herausfordernden zeit eine politische
strategie verfolgen kann die viele dann
auch mittragen wollen zurück im
bundestag ja um die ukraine geht es am
ende auch noch in deren überlebenskampf
um die unterstützung mit schweren waffen
deshalb ruft ja deshalb schreibt die
ukraine nach unserer hilfe und das mag
manchen tierisch auf den keks gehen wir
sollten aber solange bereit sein dazu
stehen so lange ist die vollständige
territoriale integrität der ukraine
wieder hergestellt wir wägen ab wir
zweifeln
ja und wir haben
aber und wir entscheiden
und das ist am ende das fazit gezählt
werden dann auch noch die stimmen 586
abgeordnete sind für den antrag 100
dagegen eine große mehrheit stimmt so
für die lieferung schwerer waffen in die
ukraine
waffen für die ukraine wir bleiben noch
beim thema die summe klingt auf englisch
noch krasser aber sie ist auch in der
deutschen übersetzung enorm dirty free
billigen dollars also 33 milliarden an
hilfe für die ukraine darunter 20
milliarden alleine für waffen und andere
militärhilfe das ist das neue paket für
das us präsident joe biden jetzt grünes
licht vom parlament will er hat sich aus
dem weißen haus heute an seine nation
gewandt das neue hilfspaket ist mehr als
doppelt so groß wie das vorangegangene
die usa stellen sich offenbar auf einen
langen krieg ein der sich auch ausweiten
könnte
da kommt etwas gewaltiges ins rollen
elmar guten abend ist das jetzt auch
eine reaktion auf die russischen
warnungen genau das zu unterlassen
ja ich glaube es ist ein doppeltes
signal zum einen das signal dass man
sich nicht einschüchtern lässt von den
video beiden sagte unnützen und
unverantwortliche bemerkungen über eine
mögliche atom installation aber zum
zweiten und das ist vielleicht wichtiger
ein signal der abschreckung denn es gibt
hinweise bei den verbündeten das
russland diesen krieg möglicherweise
ausdehnen will in andere länder zum
beispiel nach moldau und vor diesem
hintergrund will washington sehr sehr
klar machen wenn russland das tut dann
ist man bereit das militär russlands
weiter zu dezimieren indem man die
ukraine mit allem unterstützt was man
hat über die nächsten wochen über die
nächsten monate auch zu verhindern dass
die komplette küstenlinie in die hände
russlands fällt und ich glaube da haben
wir diese woche eine art
paradigmenwechsel erlebt man will ganz
klar machen dass russland sich überlegen
muss ob es diesen konflikt weiter
ausdehnen will das ist viel geld aber
wenn wir der russischen aggression
nachgeben dann wird es noch teurer hat
beiden heute gesagt wie wird die
argumentation denn von beiden ankommen
ja hier bei republikanern und demokraten
ist man sich eigentlich einig das muss
man tun es geht hier tatsächlich um mehr
als nur um die ukraine denn es ist eine
bedrohung auch für ganz europa aber es
kommt eins dazu man macht im grunde um
eine bedingung die hat man uns heute
morgen in einem hintergrundgespräch hier
gesagt da sagte ein regierungsberater
wir erwarten von unseren partnern und
verbündeten dass sie im gleichen maße
auch weiterhin die ukraine unterstützen
und das heißt im umkehrschluss auch
deutschland auch die europäischen
partner auch die g 7 werden in den
nächsten wochen und monaten mehr tun
müssen als sie bisher getan haben einmal
vielen dank für diese analyse live aus
washington und währenddessen verstärkt
russland heute seine angriffe im süden
und osten der ukraine die aktuelle
situation dort zeigt jetzt christian von
rechenberg
bilder eines britischen fernseh teams
unterwegs im osten der ukraine in serie
donetsk
in dieser region heißt es heute käme der
beschuss der angreifer aus fast allen
richtungen russland bietet für die
menschen bedeutet dass nur kurz nach
oben das nötigste holen und zurück in
die keller in sicherheit vor den
geschossen nicht vor der angst und doch
ist ihr wille ungebrochen
nein sie haben uns ganz sicher nicht
vergessen sagt diese bewohnerinnen
deswegen werde ich ganz sicher am leben
bleiben nein sie haben uns nicht
aufgegeben dass fühle ich
alles wird wieder gut werden
alles wieder gut man mag es nicht
glauben wenn man sich hier unten umsieht
und
man muss sich rasch um sehen was von
einer polizeistation übrigblieb kann das
team nur kurzfilmen schneller rundgang
dann wird's offenbar zu brenzlig
der un-generalsekretär
kritisiert weil er zuerst moskau
besuchte heute in der ukraine
er demonstriert solidarität und macht
sich ein bild von orten die borodjanka
oder butscher wo man bisher die meisten
toten zivilisten fand viele trügen
spuren von folter die ukrainische justiz
ermittelt gegen zehn ausschüsse soldaten
ich bin froh dass der internationale
strafgerichtshof auf die lage aufmerksam
geworden ist und die strafverfolger
schon hier waren ich fordere russland
auf einer zusammenarbeit mit dem
strafgerichtshof zuzustimmen
worte wie hier in cervia donetsk weit
weg klingen mögen besuch der un
untersuchung von kriegsverbrechen
ob und wann sie das hier erleben keiner
weise keine zeit sich damit zu
beschäftigen sie müssen erst versuchen
zu überleben
mehr geld mehr waffen mehr mitgliedern
eine besondere schlüsselrolle kommt
aktuell dem nato generalsekretär zu der
schweden und finnland mit offenen armen
empfangen würde im verteidigungsbündnis
wie er heute sagt
wenn die beiden länder denn einen
entsprechenden antrag stellen das wäre
eine wirklich historische zeitenwende
und sie wird immer wahrscheinlicher
auch für jens stoltenberg selbst hat
sich einiges geändert die zeiten als ihm
vorgeworfen wurde er sei bei der nato er
sekretär als general sind vorbei florian
hahn hat den norweger an der nato spitze
mal genauer beobachtet
sagen sie herr stoltenberg eigentlich
wollten sie doch aufhören hier bei der
nato ja also
mein plan war zurück nach norwegen zu
gehen und gouverneur der norwegischen
zentralbank zu werden
als ich dann gebeten wurde hier
weiterzumachen da dachte ich das ist
wichtiger dringender
unterwegs mit dem mann der in dieser
krise vielleicht zum gesicht des westens
geworden ist einer der zwar keine großen
reden halten aber dafür stets
verlässlich dieselben antworten geben
kann egal was auch immer gerade gefragt
wird
das alles untermauert von stets
derselben schneidenden handbewegung sie
lässt dann in brüssel längst über den
sprech automaten stoltenberg
sie haben recht ich bin schon vorsichtig
wegen der dinge bei die ich spreche und
die tatsache dass ich im namen von so
vielen regierungen spreche macht es
extrem wichtig dass ich vorsichtig bin
mit meiner sprache
formal hat ein generalsekretär der nato
zwar keine macht doch er setzt den ton
und im konflikt mit russland will
stoltenberg härtere töne als manchem
lieb ist
[Musik]
ausgerechnet er der in den 70er jahren
gegen den vietnamkrieg demonstrierte und
damals man glaubt es kaum für den
austritt norwegens aus der nato war
aber ich habe dann eigentlich früher
erkannt dass das eine absolut falsche
position war das ist jahrzehnte her
da war ich noch ein junger mann
später trifft er als ministerpräsident
von norwegen zum ersten mal auf vladimir
putin beschützt wie so viele damals
hoffnung
ich erinnere mich sehr gut an unser
erstes treffen im frühjahr 2001 wir
treffen uns in moskau und ich erinnere
mich an unseren optimismus jetzt wo der
kalte krieg zu ende ist und die
chaotische zeit in russland vorbei dass
wir eine neue partnerschaft begründen
können
[Musik]
dass stoltenberg genau wie die nato
heute so gefragt ist dürfte er dem
gesprächspartner von damals verdanken
am mittag dienstreise durch brüssel zum
europaparlament wo ihn unter anderem die
frage erwartet wann die nächsten länder
der nato beitreten könnten schweden und
finnland und wo es sollten werke so klar
antwortet wie bisher noch nicht
wenn diese länder sich bewerben werden
sie willkommen sein und ich erwarte dass
der prozess der aufnahme dann schnell
abläuft wie quick seinen traumjob als
notenbankchef norwegens ist übrigens
längst vergeben seinen job als
nato-generalsekretär endet nun im herbst
23 ob der konflikt bis dahin auch vorbei
ist er wagt keine prognose
wir wagen es zu hoffen zurück nach
deutschland hielt heinz der bundestag
hat beschlossen dass die sogenannte
eeg-umlage abgeschafft wird die bislang
die stromkunden zahlen müssen bei einem
durchschnittshaushalt aktuell rund 150
euro im jahr zur entlastung der
verbraucher übernimmt nun ab juli der
energie und klimafonds des bundes diese
förderung der erneuerbaren energien
ebenfalls heute im bundestag die erste
debatte zur anhebung des mindestlohns
auf 12 eur wie es der gesetzentwurf von
bundesarbeitsminister hall vorsieht er
war für diesen schritt als
sozialstaatlich geboten auch angesichts
der aktuellen preisentwicklung sei das
wichtig sagte heil wer vollzeit zum
mindestlohn arbeite verdiene bisher
brutto rund 1700 euro und nach der
erhöhung und
2100 euro diese erhöhung soll im oktober
kommen
zur corona situation derzeit gibt es in
den bundesländern unterschiedliche
regelungen wie lange sich infizierte in
isolation begeben müssen kommende woche
soll eine neue empfehlung des robert
koch instituts veröffentlicht werden die
eine isolations dauer von nur noch fünf
tagen vorsieht das kündigte er heute
abend das bundesgesundheitsministerium
bei einer video schalte der länder
gesundheitsminister an bei der
entsprechenden anpassung ihrer isolation
zum quarantäne regelungen wollen die
länder einheitlich vorgehen ist es in
einer mitteilung
die jüngste entwicklung der korona
pandemie in deutschland lässt sich aus
sicht des robert koch instituts wegen
der osterfeiertage und der osterferien
schwer einschätzen die sieben tage
incidents liegt laut lka aktuell bei
826 das rkw registrierte binnen eines
tages
130.000 104 neuinfektionen das sind 56
1221 weniger als vor einer woche
innerhalb eines tages wurden
246 todesfälle erfasst
indien und pakistan leiden unter einer
extremen hitzewelle ungewöhnlich früh
für dieses jahr indien erlebte bereits
den heißesten märz seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen vor 122 jahren die
temperaturen klettern auf weit über 40
grad teils bestehen engpässe bei strom
und wasser seit tagen kämpft die
indische feuerwehr außerdem in neu delhi
gegen einen großbrand auf einer
mülldeponie
der giftige gase über die stadt
verbreitet
wer am jom ha schoah mal in israel war
wenn das land der sechs millionen im
holocaust ermordeten juden gedenkt wer
erlebt hat wie das ist wenn laute
chaotische städte und ihre quirligen
menschen plötzlich innehalten komplett
für zwei minuten
der wird das nicht vergessen
[Musik]
bilder aus tel aviv heute vormittag
77 jahre nach dem ende des krieges
werden immer noch neue spuren des
naziterrors entdeckt im ehemaligen
ghetto theresienstadt in nordböhmen
zwischen 1941 und 45 ein kz ähnliches
gefängnis für mehr als 140.000 menschen
sind es geheime arrestzellen mit
botschaften die auf wählen wie
christhard läpple zeigt
anfang januar dieses jahres endlich
erhält touristenführer lucas neff den
schlüssel für den keller der ehemaligen
ss kommandantur von theresienstadt
seine vermutung wird gewissheit statt
leerer tresor entdeckt der tscheche ein
geheimgefängnis 7 arrestzellen für
ghetto gefangenen er entdeckt ein
türrahmen hilferufe und herzergreifende
botschaften ein tag ohne dich ist etwas
wie eine ewigkeit sowas hier sieht man
was du für mich bedeutet
das tschechische tessin eine alte
garnisonsstadt mit heute knapp 3000
einwohnern weltweit berühmt berüchtigt
als theresienstadt das nazi vorzeige
gitter für juden aus ganz europa im
bankgebäude residierte in der ersten
etage der ss kommandant die damals
16-jährige wäre rosenzweig kannte das
haus
wir sind
wir haben nichts gehört wir haben nie
gehört jemand
im geheimgefängnis wurden ghetto
insassen wegen geringster verstöße
eingesperrt zum beispiel rauchen in der
öffentlichkeit ein gefängnis im
gefängnis verzweifelt ritzten gefangenen
nachrichten einer verewigte sogar die
prager karlsbrücke
was sind die letzten spuren von menschen
ja die hier im ghetto waren sondern
danach wurden die erschossen und
verbrannt ist eigentlich das
verschwundene der juden älteste von
theresienstadt beim rapport vor ss
kommandant siegfried zettel
herr kopp edelstein rettete
leidensgenossen vor der deportation in
dem er gefangenenzahlen manipulierte der
lager älteste wurde im ss keller
eingesperrt wir finden auch seinen namen
edelstein wurde im november 44 nach
auschwitz deportiert zur
sonderbehandlung
last moment
die letzten momente von jakob miriam und
ariel edelstein warnen auschwitz sie
durften sich noch einmal kurz sehen dann
musste jakob mit ansehen wie er frauen
sohn erschossen wurden
danach wurde er selbst erschossen schon
80 jahre nach der terrorherrschaft
werden in theresienstadt neue beweise
für die verbrechen der nazis entdeckt
sie sind stumme zeugen des ns-terrors
jeder beweis sollte gesichert werden wir
sehen es heute in der ukraine wie
wichtig das ist geschichte wiederholt
sich
wer hier mit ihrem vater hat vier
schreckens orte überlebt theresienstadt
auschwitz christian stadt und bergen
belsen eine sache ist sehr wichtig sagt
die 96-jährige sie waren nie nur eine kz
nummer ich bin nicht geblieben eine
nummer
und
wahrscheinlich bin ich wirklich dick
wer ideen hat hitler 77 jahre überlebt
das ist ihr größter triumph
[Musik]
namen gesichter geschichten über
160.000 überlebende des holocaust sind
noch unter uns ihnen zuzuhören ist ein
geschenk heute und an jedem anderen tag
und jetzt hier in der sendung noch mal
so der frühere ddr bürgerrechtler werner
schulz erhält den deutschen
nationalpreis
2022 der 72 jährige der nach dem
mauerfall für die grünen zunächst im
bundestag und später im europaparlament
saß sei ein streiter für werte basierte
politik teilte die deutsche
nationalstiftung in hamburg mit der
förderpreis geht laut stiftung an den
sender ost west tv mit sitz in berlin er
sei einer der wenigen tv sender in
russischer sprache der noch unabhängig
und kritisch berichtet die
preisverleihung ist am 14 juni in berlin
auf der internationalen raumstation iss
eine neue besatzung angekommen die
ablösung für das team des deutschen
astronaut matthias maurer soll fünf
monate auf der iss bleiben die zwei
männer und zwei frauen aus den usa und
italien dockten nach rund 16 stunden
flug mit ihrer dragon kapsel an der iss
an die private raumfahrt firma spacex
brachte damit bereits zum fünften mal im
auftrag der nasa astronauten zur iss
so und jetzt empfehlen wir ihnen zwei
parteichefs einen vizekanzler und
natürlich maybrit illner was für eine
runde schwere waffen führt ihr warum
schwenkt berlin jetzt um ist das thema
und morgen freut sich an dieser stelle
die kollegin bettina schausten hier auf
sie um 0.30 meldet sich christopher
wehrmann mit dem heute-journal update
von uns allen hier ein angenehmer haben
[Musik]
guten abend hoch team bringt uns viel
sonnenschein einige quellwolken auch mal
küssten nebel an der ostsee und von
nordwesten einige hohe wolkenfelder die
ziehen heute nacht schon zu uns rein
häufig aber ist es klar und selten
bildet sich nebel die temperaturen in
der nacht sinken auf werte zwischen plus
7 und minus 1 grad und steigen morgen
auf 11 grad an der nordseeküste und bis
21 grad am oberrhein am vormittag gibt
es hier in süddeutschland noch sehr viel
sonne auch in sachsen sonst sind schon
viele hohe wolkenfelder unterwegs und
die ziehen im laufe des nachmittags
weiter nach südosten dann könnte die
sonne im nordwesten noch mal völlig
hinter wolken verschwinden in den
nächsten tagen geht es für die meisten
mit freundlichem frühlingswetter weiter
es wird allerdings von süden und
südwesten unbeständiger dann drohen auch
mal gewitter und das bei temperaturen
von 12 bis 20 grad an allen drei tagen
und jetzt verlassen wir mitteleuropa und
schauen noch mal nach pakistan sie haben
schon von der extremen hitzewelle in
indien und pakistan gehört hier im süden
pakistans erwarten wir jetzt
höchsttemperaturen von lebensfeindlichen
50 grad und auch nachts kühlt es kaum
noch ab bei 25 bis 30 grad diese 50 grad
wären dann rekord für die jahreszeit vor
der globalen erwärmung war eine solche
hitze wenn er etwa alle 50 jahre zu
erwarten jetzt alle vier jahre guten
abend